[Applause]
one o'clock in central kabul and taliban
security forces run towards the site of
an explosion smoke leads them towards
dalhan military hospital across the road
from the now abandoned u.s embassy
one device was detonated at the hospital
entrance allowing attackers to move in
20 minutes later a second exploded
inside the compound
this man films from inside the hospital
repeating god have mercy on us as he
watches the attack take place
people shelter where they can as fires
from the explosions burn and gunmen move
between buildings
dozens of others managed to reach the
back of the hospital compound
watchtowers and security walls that were
meant to keep them safe in sight now
their biggest obstacle to escape
above afghan air force helicopters
circled flown by pilots from the
previous government who are now part of
the taliban's defence
taliban responded by sending their
special forces to the site of the attack
after the first explosion and they've
created quite a large cordon around
where the attack has taken place as
spread at gunfire has continued
throughout the afternoon
there were two explosions and six
attackers all of them were killed the
security forces of the taliban are in
the area and our special badger units
are here who are very quick in their
operations the whole area is now under
our control
the taliban know how to secure the
military hospital because they know its
weaknesses they attacked it themselves
ten years ago
isil fighters also targeted the hospital
in 2017
then they dressed as doctors to evade
security more than 100 people were
killed and injured
isil has challenged the taliban's
hold-on security since it came to power
in august the group has carried out four
major bombings and killed hundreds of
civilians the worst was at kabul airport
as tens of thousands of people evacuated
the last foreign military forces
withdrew
the main thing that people really much
need and want from taliban was
their grip over the security and their
last era if they lose
that grip
if the
insecurity increases i think
it will somehow
discredit taliban's presence in the
power
the taliban has downplayed the threat of
isil but the group is getting harder to
ignore taliban casualties are mounting
as isil targets its members particularly
in eastern provinces
still in kabul taliban members respond
like the previous government would have
just a few months ago they've set up a
large cordon to protect the public
special forces and air cover are
deployed intelligence units gather
evidence but people here are hoping for
more a stop to attacks altogether
charlotte ballas al jazeera kabul